a lot of people holding at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 let's go next to our caller from
the 608 area code caller from 608 who's
there 608 you might be muted but the
thing that is you who's this hi this is
Jeremy from Wisconsin
hey Jeremy what's going on hey I was
just wondering about your position on
the recent venezuelan controversy
surrounding Maduro I saw the video you
made about how people in the progressive
movement are kind of overlooking the
evils and Venezuelan government and I
was wondering what your solution would
be towards getting Maduro out of office
yeah I didn't I don't know that I used
the term evil necessarily but I've
pointed out that whatever your position
is on American intervention and I'm
against it to be very clear that Nicolas
Maduro and Hugo Chavez the late Hugo
Chavez were not beacons of progressive
populism beyond their rhetoric and are
actually hugely authoritarian leaders
much more reminiscent of the folks that
usually the left would not be aligned
with so I think that the this is an area
of this some disagreement with my
audience I think the confusion is coming
in that I am pointing out that there are
reflexive defenses of Maduro coming from
some areas of the left that are focused
only on american interventionism or the
word colonialism or imperialism is
thrown out there and I've been accused
by some it's sort of shocking because
I've never said anything of the sort
that because I'm opposed to Nicolas
Maduro that I somehow support American
intervention or invasions for oil or
whatever that's simply not the case so I
think you know I don't know exactly how
do you get Maduro out I don't know the
answer to that but I think it's
important what I was thinking yeah but
what I was thinking was this kind of
goes to a question of the strength of
international bodies like the you
for example yep having a body that you
know coalesce is different governments
and is able to establish if a regime is
legitimate or not and can take recourse
but I think people are just sort of like
you said reflexively pushing back
against you know American intervention
and taking out on you which I know you
didn't say you want America to go in but
that's typically the rhetoric people use
they talk about how evil majora is and
they you know they rationalize that with
trying to push America into the news
whele
to get more resource yeah and I mean
there's a spent there's a sort of a
special pleading going on because I'm
against I don't like president air
dawuan I don't like Kim jong-eun I don't
like Vladimir Putin
I don't like Bashar al-assad I don't
like the Qatari royal family you know
like I'm not an authoritarian Saudi
Arabia that doesn't mean that I'm
supportive of american-led regime change
in those places right and I think that
it's really important to take these
things in their component parts thank
you for the call
okay appreciate your call thank you very
much